[Music]
one of the biggest shows on television
these days is amc's the walking dead
this sunday season premiere got bigger
ratings among adults than any
entertainment series this fall that is
huge yeah well i was just told a few
minutes ago that a big fan of the
walking dead is here tonight we've asked
him to come out and briefly explain the
popularity of the show i haven't met him
yet i'm told he's here right now please
welcome hamilton davis let's get him in
here hamilton
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm sorry hamilton you you look like a
zombie
i am a zombie
although the politically correct term is
decaying american
can we get this straight zombies watch
the walking dead duh
of course we're big fans the show
presents us as the complex creatures we
are crafty resourceful with an
insatiable zest for life
what are you talking about your
relentless killing machines bent on
destroying humanity
point taken
but we also enjoy fine wine art gallery
openings and the novels of joyce carol
oates
okay none of that is portrayed in the
show
it's strongly implied
i guess some of us are better at
grasping subtext than others
okay if you're so sophisticated why do
you wear those filthy old zombie clothes
hello this is shabby chic
this suit's made of pre-dispressed
portuguese linen and it cost more than
your car
all right you know what you're being
really rude i mean i invited you on my
television show you call this a
television show
looks more like an elementary school
production of
crap
you know what you're being awfully
obnoxious for a guy who shuffles around
eating brains
i'd love to eat some brains but at this
show they're clearly in short supply
you know what i've had it with this jerk
[Music]
hey einstein you have to shoot a zombie
in the head
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i have the feeling he's still alive yeah
still alive
still alive
are you still in
well
i'm not doing very well
he's got the death
[Applause]